no one likes finding bugs in their food
when they're not expecting it but I hate
to break it to you you're actually
eating them all the time now I'm not
just talking about the critters that end
up in juices or jams by accident some
bugs are in our food because well we put
them there if you think it's fruit that
turns this strawberry yogurt red think
again yes there are in fact strawberries
in there but they're there for flavor
and texture not color that bright red
comes from something else called carmine
oh and it's made from squash bugs
squashed female cochineal bugs to be
specific there tick sized critters
native to meso America where they suck
the juice from prickly pear cactuses and
if you squish them they are bright red
inside what kind of a purple a deep
purple red color and that's the source
of coach Neil coaching yield I've Carm
and whatever you want to call it for
thousands of years people have been
using these bugs to die everything from
clothes to pottery but it wasn't until
more recently that they made their way
into commercial foods from 1955 to 2010
the consumption of food coloring rose by
500%
in the United States that's mostly
thanks to artificial colors like red 40
yellow 5 and blue 1 but in the late 20th
century consumers became increasingly
concerned about synthetic chemicals in
their foods and demanded more natural
ingredients so many companies turned to
carmine it's fda-approved and tasteless
it resists degradation from light heat
and oxidation and unlike some synthetic
colorants it hasn't been linked to
cancers or tumor growth
now some people apparently have
allergies to it but compared with the
downsides of a chemical dye it's very
benign it's like using beach you
you know and just like that carmine
ended up in strawberry and cream
frappuccinos and cake pops at Starbucks
in Tropicana grapefruit juice and yes in
Yoplait yogurt
just look for a carmine or cochineal
extract on the label to see for yourself
but today carmine is becoming harder and
harder to come by
some companies like Campari group maker
of the famous Campari aperitif have
faced it out for economic reasons in the
u.s. it's expensive to make I mean it's
not it's easier to just make a chemical
dye stand this is a very specialized you
know you have to farm these little bugs
and collect billions of pounds of them
and drawing them and all that so I think
that's it just wasn't as practical other
companies took it out because well
people still don't like eating bugs
especially vegans in 2012 a vegan new
site out at Starbucks for using
cochineal and its strawberries and cream
Frappuccino saying that it's not vegan
and a month later the company said
they'd switched to a bug-free
alternative in fact Yoplait now remains
one of the only major brands that sells
food colored with carmine but even yo
plate may phase it out after customers
expressed concerns about eating bug
parts so i just think it's ironic people
are freaked out about insects while
eating insects even though we eat 2
pounds of insects a year on average by
accident and to show just how harmless
they are we tried some nope just tastes
like yogurt not buggy at all in fact not
that I would know what that would taste
like but I'm really just getting plain
Greek yogurt tastes